uh the uk is to become the first in the
world to allow
volunteers to be exposed to covid19
as part of a research trial to increase
our understanding of how the virus
affects people
as many as 90 volunteers aged between 18
and 30 are said to be taking part or
reporter becky cottrell
has more of the detail i mean this is
this is fascinating but one wonders
who and earth is going to be putting
themselves up for this trial
yeah well you say that but but actually
what they're looking at
with uh this study they're they're
actually going to expose the volunteers
to the original
form of the virus that really started to
circulate here in march 2020
and that original form the virus is seen
to be less dangerous
to adults between kind of 18 to 30 and
those are the people
that the researchers want to take part
in the study as you say it's a first of
its kind it's called a human
challenge study and it basically
involves deliberately exposing
volunteers to covid now that isn't a new
model it's been done before with malaria
and typhoid but it is the first time
it's been done with covert and the
reason it's taken us
so long to get to this point that the
trial is now coming to into effect
within the month
is because of those clear ethical
concerns around deliberately
exposing people to the virus they'll try
and make it as safe as possible the
volunteers will be studied 24 hours a
day
by medical professionals and what
they're really trying to look at is
how the immune system responds to the
virus but also what's going on with
vaccines and they'll be
they'll be using different vaccines that
have been approved to see
which is most effective at helping the
volunteers
to cope with covid and this really is a
vital research at a time when we're
trying to learn not only
how the virus works and what's going on
with different mutations
but also as the government is looking to
ease lockdown measures